he's one of our go-to's and uh love
every single time that he is on at nfl
stroud on twitter i follow him you
should as well joining us here on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line to tell us
what's going on in tampa is from the
tampa eight times rick stroud how you
doing
rick i feel a lot like bruce arians i
think that i can confirm that was
exactly his reaction
yeah he was he was fired up man he was
if you could text the motion he was
texting me emotion with i love his
little cocktail glasses that you know
the little emojis there oh he he's got a
cocktail emoji glassy absolutely like a
stiff drink i like it had a couple of
them last night to me so yeah he was uh
he was having a good time so how did
this all come about rick walk me through
it best you can tell well i mean it's
bet as best as i can you know figure um
and and i've you know talked to people
that uh
you know around tom i mean you don't
actually get tom very often but
um they had said look give this guy 90
days well it only took 40 right and uh
we know it you know noah built an ark in
40 days so you can make up your mind
about a lot of things but
i i think uh you know i i think it's
something that
he is you know more than hinted at he
has said i don't know how i feel he said
never say never
um you know a lot of those sort of uh
open door thing jason light was going to
keep the light on for him right
which is a t-shirt somewhere for
somebody to make but i think that
you know
when i talk to coaches and talk to
people they stayed in contact with brady
and they didn't always talk about
football
but there's been a lot of dialogue and i
think over the last four or five days
maybe
and i know this rich because you know
something's really hot of course they
were in it for for deshaun watson i mean
they were looking at that situation uh
as well but but when everybody that you
trust that you have access to goes zero
dark 30 on you you know something's
really hot you know and so uh i think i
think you know the way the clumsy roll
out of the retirement in the first place
probably bothered him you know tom was
gonna be the only one that announced at
this time they managed to keep that
under wraps at least for him to do that
and um you know i i think
they never shut the door you know i
think the bucks played this perfectly
right they they obviously had to look at
their options and they were ready to
move forward with it and the timing is
not coincidental i mean we're sitting
here now we have started the free agent
negotiating period they've already lost
guard alex kappa um but since brady
announced his that he was coming back
they they resigned ryan jensen their
center and they they resigned aaron
stinney even before the announcement so
they'll be able to retain some of these
free agents now and if he's going to
play
he wanted them to know that and he
wanted he wanted to be the greatest
recruiter in the nfl which he has been
so
um all of that
sort of you know sort of got us to where
we're at today any sense at all of when
it really solidified because
again it was just six days
after his social media
blitz um interestingly enough a day
after he could have done it on his own
podcast and didn't take that shot that
he did appear on his let's go pod and
said never say never
to the concept of being done
and then you know uh fred couples uh
during kanban week he winds up on fred's
podcast and says something along the
lines of he's just enjoying hanging out
with his family and he's sleeping in his
own childhood bedroom and you know and
then he'll he'll assess things how
things look in june
and at that point in time he had to be
well down the road of of of this
decision any idea about the timing of
when he actually decided this was not
going to happen
yeah you know i've asked people that and
i can't get a straight answer and maybe
it's because they don't know
maybe tom tom will have to tell us if
there was a moment right um when he was
doing something watching something
for the near as i can figure you know
and talking to people around him coaches
and whatnot it came down to this the guy
can still flat-out play he's a football
player this is what he does and he does
it as well as anyone in the world he
always has he just finished the season
you know where you know he led the nfl
in passing 5316 yards 43 touchdowns if
not for
um you know a a couple of bad defensive
plays he brought him back you know
against the rams you know what down
24 points and tied that game and they go
in overtime they win that they host the
49ers and maybe they beat the cincinnati
bengals in the super bowl i mean that's
how close
these games are sometimes when you get
into the postseason we saw that so
he feels like he has a chance to win and
he knows he can play and and i just
think you know he needed that time um
i don't know exactly what the pressure
was to to to announce his retirement
when he did
um i don't know the forces behind that
but
i think that you know every offseason he
does kind of the same thing right he
takes a lot of time spends a lot of time
with his family does a lot of traveling
um and
i i don't think he could stomach come
august when the training camps opened
not not being in the mix not knowing
that he's as good or better than
most of the quarterbacks out there if
not all of them and and that he could he
could still lead a team and that's
that's what he loves to do i mean he's
not many of these guys there's exactly
one of them but he loves to play the
game i mean i think his love of football
as much as anything is what this is
about and you know certainly he doesn't
have to prove anything to anybody else
but himself
and i just think he felt like he would
be too miserable watching right now
knowing that he's that good and he can
still make a difference and and lead a
team to a championship and then one last
one on the timing of it him being at the
man you
um game of match pardon me um over the
weekend was that just coincidence he
always wanted to take his family to old
trafford or was he locking things up
with the glazer family uh and face to
face
well with convenient timing i don't know
you know
tom can pretty much fire up his own
plane anytime he wants right and you'd
have to make reservations right yeah i
don't know if it works like that but um
you know certainly
i think people
a couple of things rich we've talked
about this on your show you know this
narrative that there was you know bad
feelings between the bucks or or bruce
aryans you know i i don't think any of
that was ever true i know how much he
respects the glazers how grateful he is
certainly they're grateful to him um you
know he brought him a lombardi trophy
and all that notoriety and and they're
relevant again and they are again for
2022. so i i think they would have
you know listened to tom and and
accepted whatever decision he had
um but but i think we'd be naive to
think that you know while i'm sure he
wanted to go see ronaldo play
um you know and bring his sons and
that's that's a great experience uh you
know that that team is owned by the
glazer family and that that shows again
um that there is a trust there there's a
bond there and you know this this notion
that he would go play somewhere else i
never really thought that that was a
great possibility um you know the 49ers
had said no to him when they drafted g.o
carmarzi they said no to him when he
left new england i don't think he was
going to give him a chance to say no a
third time
um so if he was gonna play he was gonna
play here
and that's what the bucks had been
telling us and i think he had to take
him at their word and i think
you know just the way they went about it
you know
doing their homework doing their
research ready to move on if they needed
to but always keeping that door open the
light on whatever i think that was
important so i'm sure he let the owners
know the good news when he was out there
i think he certainly knew by then and
from what i understand he's known for
several days rick stroud here on the
rich eisen show from the tampa bay times
so you just said moments ago that uh you
were told when brady announced he was
done um you know give him 90 days and he
took 40 and that's how long it took noah
to build an ark so um
i'm just wondering how how does lombardi
come in twos now in tampa
um
and so what what now what what are the
maneuvers that you're that you know
jason leiter is working on right now
with the new league year officially
coming in a couple of days what do you
think well he's got a lot yeah he's got
a lot of important free agents to
re-sign and and i think you know they
started that process when they
franchised chris godwin who i think they
absolutely want to get a long-term
extension with him
probably prior to the start of the new
league year if they can that's when the
salary cap matters
and that's 19.2 million dollars that
they would rather not have in that form
on the cap and so
you know i think they're focused on that
um they obviously and i mentioned that
they resigned you know a guard uh really
two of them if you count aaron stenny so
they're going to have the five
linemen that uh started the super bowl
and and two other playoff games which
isn't a bad place they got to do some
work at receiver um you know we know
godwin's resigned but they they were
thin at that position whether that's
through the draft
and and they've got to you know keep
that defense intact i mean i think
carlton davis is going to get a lot of
action you know and he may leave we
don't know they still have sean murphy
bunting they still have jamal dean they
have guys back there um jordan whitehead
there's a real impact safety that they
would like to keep if they could um and
then you've got guys like sue i'm not
sure if he moves on or not in jpp or
different situations because they're
older players and i think they want to
get younger on the defensive line but
the goal is you know let's build a
championship team and when you have tom
brady you know you're in the mix you
know guys
um will want to win a ring and and i
just think that you know
they have to do everything they can push
more money back if they have to um
because you take every year as a gift
and and this was certainly one that um
you know that it kind of came back to
them and and they're not gonna waste the
opportunity they're gonna try to go for
it again and then what about brady
because technically this was the
window dressing year right uh of
whatever contract that clearly they were
hoping he'd play on it but what the
number's like 10 million bucks he's not
playing on that number right so the
question is what about him and do we see
a contract where there's a so-called you
know window dressing year to to push
things around salary cap
that will leave us over the next year
wondering if brady will play that one
too right like what what about that rick
strauss yeah rich he needs a new
contract there's no question because he
had 15 16 million dollars of a deferred
uh bonus that that you know disappeared
and and he's not going to play for 10
million bucks or whatever is left on it
so they'll have to do a new deal with
him and i would i would anticipate for
salary cap reasons much like he did a
year ago that that'll include an extra
year
um which could fall off in the future or
he could play and it kind of
accomplishes two things right because
you know the first question that he's
going to get and the one thing tom brady
never wanted i think it's probably still
doesn't is is a retirement tour you know
he doesn't want a farewell he doesn't he
doesn't want the rocking chairs and the
gifts and that's the last thing this guy
wants he wants you to think he could
play to his 50 and maybe he will and
this i think you have to look at it year
to year clearly but i would expect
another year to be added to his deal
because it accomplishes a lot of things
and he can say look i'm signed for two
seasons you know i'm not thinking about
next year i'm focusing on winning i mean
i know exactly what he's going to say so
um that'll absolutely happen uh sooner
than later and then gronk is a formality
for the tommy and gronkey show right
that's it yeah man it's got to be right
i mean that was that's such a good thing
you know like i can picture him now
yelling at you know hey mom where's my
football plan you know that whole thing
is probably going on in gronk's house
right now
um so you know tommy was at a uh he was
at a strawberry festival concert now tom
brady doesn't like strawberries as you
know so he didn't accompany him to that
but he was at a concert the other night
in tampa he's been working out at the
bucks facility a couple days a week from
what i understand bruce arians told us
so
i got to believe that uh you know before
before tom came back the first call he
made was probably the gronk and said uh
we're back baby you know and and that's
uh that's what i would expect would
happen good times rolling still right
man they're in tampa the folks there
must be out of their minds out of their
minds thinking that this thing was over
and it's going to be gabbert and who
knows 24 free agents are coming and the
team is going to have to turn upside
down and aaron's is going to have to
start over again
um unfortunately for leftwitch and
bowles they did not get head coaching
jobs but fortunately for the bucks
they're just running it back best they
can right four net two i mean like is
that is that expected i mean how do we
put everybody back together it but it
looks it i i don't know about leonard i
mean i don't know if they'll move on
from him or not he's got a saying that
and i think they're always you know
looking to to upgrade and whatnot but
um yeah rich it was weird waking up this
morning it was you know first of all i
don't know about you guys i'm screwed up
with this whole time change thing you
know and it's like i said earlier it's
like it's it's it's jason light savings
time right now right because
he's the guy he's the guy that's uh
that's running the show over here and
everybody's excited felt like it's i
felt like i woke up and it was 20 20
again i mean it really has that kind of
buzz to it you know and if you've been
in this league and you've covered teams
like the bucks and and others that lost
for so many years you only went 12 years
without the playoffs until tom came you
know there's two sides of the nfl right
there's the side where you're always
grinding you're trying to find a
quarterback you're rebuilding you know
you have a five-year plan a 10-year plan
hell these guys had a 12-year plan and
it never came together and then you get
on the other side of the nfl where you
win 29 games in two years in a super
bowl and you forget you know just just
how how ugly uh the other side can be
and that's where they were headed i mean
with kyle trask blaine gabbard no
disrespect but that team was not going
to probably contend for a championship
and they've got a they've got a tough
road i mean brady's taking a chance here
a little bit i mean he could still play
we know he can win the nfc south i think
we'll see you know they might be playing
deshawn watson in new orleans or
carolina but that schedule take a look
at it i mean they play everybody that
was in the playoffs last year i mean
they've got cincinnati they got kansas
city um you know
they've got arizona and san francisco
and the rams and pittsburgh and
baltimore i mean it is a daunting
schedule
that these guys play and they also got a
game in germany which will which will uh
you know be quite an event so
um you know you don't you you know
there's no guarantee tom has another
great year he certainly can do it but
you know we never want to see him be
like ben or or or drew brees at the end
of his career either so he's rolling the
dice but he's betting on himself and
that's always been the best bet in the
nfl love it rick stroud thanks the time
as always you take care of yourself man
take care guys appreciate it look for my
call we'll be coming again soon always
does thanks it's rick stroud right here
on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here